for a French actress playing Shakespeare
whether directed by an Australian or not
can seem extremely intimidating as well
as exhilarating when you were first
approached were your feelings more one
way or the other no when I was
approached approach how I thought it was
it was really weird to ask to a French
actress to play Lady Macbeth but at the
same time I didn't I didn't freak out
right away I thought it was yeah it was
an amazing gift to be able to to play
Shakespeare in his own language and and
also I had had this very special
relationship with Lady Macbeth without
never exploring this character but when
I was in acting school and I saw one of
the students work on Lady Macbeth
soliloquy and that day I thought I know
that one day I will have this experience
but I thought it would be on stage and
in French so when they approached me I
thought that was an opportunity that I
could miss I had decided not to work
because I had worked a lot with very
dramatic characters and I needed to go
to my happier life but but then I
thought this is this is something that I
need to do and also the director Justin
Herzl it was his second movie so I
thought wow this guy's like a hundred
person crazy
choosing this house the second movie and
asking a French actress to play Lady
Macbeth but then I talked to him on the
phone and and I felt that that was the
kind of director I really wanted to work
with totally involved committed I mean
telling stories for him is something
that is that he needs to do he needs to
be on set he needs to tell amazing
stories and he works with actors like me
it would
one of my best experiences in terms of
direction so and then and then I started
to freak out and then I read the script
and I didn't understand a word I mean I
knew the the play and the story
obviously but but the words those words
that I had never read this before I had
so but we then had like a month and a
half of rare Souls and that was really
amazing we worked with Neal Swain who
was our dialect coach but was also a
Shakespeare expert and he really helped
us to explore Shakespeare in this play
and we went really deep into studying
the play so that didn't stop me to freak
out the whole shooting long but but at
least I was I mean I was doing it and I
and I understood what I was saying but
even a decision like the famous out
damns a out damn spot you deliver that
in the chapel again and it's this really
long take I was aware that for an actor
this must be perhaps an even greater
challenge doing it all in one take in
extreme close-up and what a shock at the
end of the scene to see the child right
there and I was wondering if for you was
it a little harder or easier in a long
take and was the child there the whole
time were you actually looking at the
child or was it more of the soliloquy
well the idea that he had that it would
be one long shot was I didn't know when
I got on when I came on set and we
started and we there was like many cuts
but then suddenly he came to me and he
said well I might keep it and keep keep
it in one long shot I was
Wow okay hmm
so we did it and when I remember when I
watched the movie for the first time I
didn't I still didn't know that if he
would use only one take and and I was
watching and I was like my god he won't
cut and I was like trying to remember
what I did was it like strong enough was
it but the fact that the child was with
me the whole time even even if it's not
that easy to work with a child because
he was like looking at me well what is
she doing like and he didn't really care
but sometimes he was looking at me and
he was not into it at all but at the
same time he's not supposed to be into
it and he's not supposed to be here so I
was I used everything he did and but
sometimes he would give me that look
like really like oh he looked like me
like I was a crazy person which she
actually is but she doesn't know it so
it was like a mix of things that I used
but of course it made it so simple that
he was there and I was talking to him
and I thought it was it was an amazing
idea that Justin had did you watch any
of the previous film versions of Macbeth
whether the Polanski 1971 or Orson
Welles from 48 or did you studiously
stay away from seeing Jeannette Nolan or
Francesca Annis interpretation well I
had seen those movies but I mean years
before and I didn't I didn't want to
watch anything because all those
actresses and particularly for me Judi
Dench who really reached perfection her
Lady Macbeth was like timeless and
really perfect
and I didn't want to look at them I
wanted to forget them because the
pressure was already like really high
and and and it would have been it would
have been horrible for me to watch Judi
Dench again because I would have been
like there's nothing I can do it was a
lake run away and quit that this
production in Justin's vision would be
his vision it would be very different
from the movies before so I thought you
just because I thought how am I gonna do
something different how am I gonna do
something that is I didn't even have in
my mind like as good as the performances
before because it was just like
impossible but I thought I just have to
put myself in the hands of Justin and he
will do something different and he will
make me do something different so I
trusted a hundred percent and and that's
when I had this thought of being with
him and that no matter what would happen
it would be different it would be unique
that I started to like stop questioning
the how can I do something that is as
good as what was what was done before
but the pressure the pressure was the
pressure was really high